go blue to Jalen Rose how are you Jalen
thanks for having me on rich appreciate
the law come on you know that so let's
start with last night before we get to
JaJuan and him being introduced as the
new HC at the University of Michigan
Jalen Rose here in the Honda inside a
report was last night at all surprising
to you Jalen it was not surprising to me
and I'm not foolish enough to not give
respect to the dynastic situation that
the Golden State Warriors have built
I've been in the gym and watch them win
three of the last four championships
understand if they're healthy they're
the favorites to win four out of five
but when you look at the dynamics of
their team it has changed from when they
first one championship before KD arrived
in their motto and rightfully so with
strength in numbers to now
mirror depleted team and currently
they're either playing with or without
three of their top six players in KD
Andre Iguodala who was hobbled at the
end of yesterday's game and DeMarcus
Cousins who is now returning from injury
that's three of their top six players so
I felt coming into this series that they
should struggle going against the
frontline other Toronto Raptors because
they're productive they're physical
they're veterans
Kawhi Leonard Pascal siakam Marc the
soul and that played out in Game one and
that's why I picked the Toronto Raptors
on paper to win this series before I
started I saw that in the pregame last
night you got so upset that Paul Pierce
chose the Raptors right before you to
jail our reaction was priceless no you
got to stick with the plan and that's
your thought I mean don't make anybody
else influence you in that but that was
a funny reaction that you had on all of
that so what was it like in the building
last night Jalen so the building was
electric and I want to paint everybody a
picture for somebody that's in Toronto
right now
and was fortunate enough to play three
seasons here so Ronald is one of the top
three MBA cities
Bar None ask any player ask any coach
when you're in California they have four
professional teams in Los Angeles they
have two so your interest is going to be
split it's just human nature and usually
people gravitate to the teams that have
the most championships that's kind of
how it works in Toronto they're the only
squad representing a country they have a
nation behind them so rich there's
20,000 people at the MB arena but it's
30,000 people in Jurassic Park outside
of the arena the only time you get those
scenes in the United States are for
parade and so to have that level of
support that they have and have the team
make it to the playoff the six straight
years and Masai Ujiri pull off great
chess moves in deciding that the team
had maximized under coach of the year
delaying KC another perennial all-star
demar derozan
that he was going to turn the reins over
to a first-year NBA coach and Nick nurse
and acquire Kawhi Leonard in the final
year of his contract and get this team
to his first NBA Finals in 25 seasons so
they have a lot of momentum on their
side along with home court advantage and
it was just it came through the TV Jalen
it just jumped through the TV and it
grabbed me by the lapels and it was
great to see but obviously that's just
one game what what a Steve Kerr thinking
about right now other than what he can't
control Durant's calf muscle what has
Kerr take out of last night to try and
tinker to draw blood and go home and try
and take a commanding lead in this
Finals so we get so enamored with the
Golden State Warriors offense and
rightfully so but this is it the team
that used to surround the 3-point line
with four or five players that can shoot
38% from three and then you have the
splash brothers who clearly both can go
off for a major game at any time
they got to get back to defending
they're not getting stops
draymond Green just came out recently
and talked about how he felt like he was
the greatest defender in the history of
the NBA and if somebody that watched him
playing high school Washington played
four years in a big jam in college
reinvent his body reinvent his game and
become the player that we saw against
Cortland that was really dominant Pascal
siakam had his way against draymond in
the half court in transition he was
making threes he was dropping dimes he
was getting layups he was getting dunks
they have to find a way to get back to
defend the Raptors shot 50% from the
floor so the Golden State Warriors
that's going to be the challenge for
dream on for Klay can they lead the
Warriors on that side of the floor and
then allow that to convert to high
percentage offense now I saw last night
Jalen as well that Chauncey Billups made
his prediction conditional on the health
of Durant
do you believe Durant must come back and
play for the Warriors to win this series
no KD no ring that's basically how I
feel about this year and I was gonna
joke with Chauncey tomorrow but I'm glad
you brought it up rich and thank you for
paying attention to details the heads in
his bed number one but number two I
looked on a social media page I kid you
not
it says Golden State Warriors in seventh
on his IG page so I don't know who he
thinks gonna win the series but I'll
tell you this if KD doesn't come back
until approximately the fifth game but
if it's 3-1 at that time Toronto Raptors
I believe clearly they go on to win now
if it's 2-2 it becomes an interesting
quandary for KD and the team because
that's going to be a lot of pressure on
him the team is going to have to adjust
to having him back in the lineup and
even though he's a great player they're
still playing a lot different with him
out there's a lot more moving there's a
lot more cutting there's a lot more
dribble handoffs now when you have KD is
more at the elbow Lord
submitted posts more trying to get
drives to the basket and so trying to
integrate him in Game four or Game five
of our NBA Finals
when you're either tired or trailing
he's in the final year of his deal we
don't know if he's gonna be a hundred
percent and he hasn't practiced with the
team yet so those dynamics don't work in
the Gosei Warriors favor at this point
of the series certainly do not Jalen
Rose in the Honda inside a rapport where
I haven't spoken in a bit so I know this
has been a topic of discussion for weeks
so I'll ask you anyway here do you think
Durant knows what his status is
would come July first that he really you
know he's selling property in the Bay
Area buying a spot in New York meaning
he's going to the Knicks or maybe even
obviously Brooklyn do you think he knows
right now what's gonna happen July 1st I
think he's 75% has a gut feeling of what
he wants to do but this is going to be
one of the most fascinating NBA
offseason with trade depending on what
happened and with Anthony Davis and/or
Chris Paul in free agency Kawhi Leonard
klay Thompson Kevin Durant
Kemba Walker boogie cousins of Jimmy
Butler Tobias Harris there's so many
players that are going to be on a free
agent market Kyrie Urban that it's going
to be an opportunity to reshuffle the
day you have the Lakers who have an
opportunity to add a max player to go
with LeBron you have the Clippers to
have an opportunity to Matt to max
players you're the Knicks and the nets
both get add to players so I think a lot
it's largely going to depend on not only
a great player like KD choosing a
destination but obviously figuring if
somebody's going to go play in that
destination with him so I can't wait to
see how it plays out and this is one of
the more I NBA finals where you look out
on the floor and you see a Kawhi Leonard
and potentially Kevin Durant if he
returns and you can say wow the two best
players of both NBA Finals teams have
not committed to playing with those T's
past this season that has never had
then okay I've been paying attention to
the game so I can't wait to see what
those guys are gonna ultimately decide
all right Jalen let's turn to coach
Juwan Howard of the University of
Michigan basketball program head coach
of that program if I had told you back
in the day that this would happen you
decide what I would have said big new
head coach University of Michigan not
gonna be able to do it and what I want
people to understand and rich my U of M
brother you see and understand the the
growth that every person has from
college to being in their forties we got
a chance to play ours out on the
national stage I would not have seen
myself being the founder of a
tuition-free charter high school when I
was in college the skinny bumpy face kid
that had a chip on his shoulder
the same thing about JaJuan a guy from
Chicago that decided he was going to go
to the University of Michigan and the
day he committed is the day that his
grandmother passed away and she meant
everything to him and then along with
the coaching staff Steve Fisher and
Brian Dutcher became a lead catalyst to
recruit the other four members to come
play at the University of Michigan and
the difference between he and I even
back then he was always the adult in the
room he was always the voice of reason
he was always mature you never see any
without a crease in his pants you never
seen any without a haircut you never
have them you never saw him have put in
the mouth type of moment that all
college kids had but for some reason he
had a level of maturity that he was able
to avoid those pitfalls and then you go
on to the league and play 19 years get
paid a maximum contract be an all-star
win a championship late in your career
with LeBron James and Dwyane Wade join
the coach of staff of Erik Spoelstra one
of the tops in the game get a chance to
be under the stewardship of Pat Riley
the great matriarch in NBA history he
paid his dues six years as a coach
sitting on the bench sitting behind the
bench coaching summer league get NBA
interviews with the Lakers and the Cavs
in a couple of their teams the Knicks
and so the timing worked out perfect
that Jim beat John Beilein left when he
did because now you look to say who's
the best candidate for this job right
now in his Juwan Howard he just so
happens to be an alum he just so happens
to be a member of the Fab five so I'm
really happy for him to be the leader of
the program and obviously we're gonna be
there and do all we can to help support
him do what he can to try to achieve his
goals now I know you've said this on
ESPN and I know you've you know I had to
see Webb on last week to and he said
we're all gonna be there are you all
gonna be there every is the band getting
back together jaylen under one roof for
one goal and I don't care I just love to
have fun to be happy the boys are back
in town yes and here's the thing there
was a fracture in a relationship between
the University of Michigan and the FAFSA
it happens in families it happens with
your friends and it always varies on how
you're feeling about the situation so
for me as a Detroit native why I was not
being acknowledged as a former
basketball player I still was a donor I
still have a scholarship endowment this
graduated a couple of kids I've actually
had a couple of my kids from the jaina
world Leadership Academy not only attend
Michigan but I have one graduate already
and another was going to graduate later
in the year so I've never stopped loving
the University but when there was a
separation and Chris had to do his 10
years I was like I'm gonna ride with my
brother so from 1994 to 2011 I didn't go
back to campus either and I didn't talk
about the relationship that we have on
one another
I didn't talk about my relationship with
the school unless I was at and you
started this interview by saying I'm on
as many shows as probably anybody in the
industry so when I get asked about real
time situations
what is the NBA Finals or whether it's
what's happening with Michigan I'm gonna
give a respectable answer and so now all
of a sudden the separation has ended so
how can Michigan now say we're gonna
also bury the hatchet they did it and
drop the mic by hiring Juwan Howard that
lets you know that the relationship went
from being one that we seem to almost
tolerate each other to now we're family
again so yes I do anticipate that
happening and we're gonna be there to
support JaJuan to support the program
and you know this rich we want to win
like Michigan has a unique fan base and
respect on campus that unlike other
schools some of them are considered only
football schools some on consider
basketball schools we respect to be in
the top 10 in both at all times and to
be the only school in the in college
right now Division one to have a former
football player Jim Harbaugh and a
former basketball player Juwan Howard
leading leading those programs it just
feels different let me give you an
example
Coach Cal is one of the best coaches in
collegiate basketball has done a
terrific job wherever he's been UMass
Memphis and now conduct Kentucky well
he's been the the matriarch of the
one-and-done
he owned it even when Coach K was
denying it he did a great job in Memphis
but it's just different when you hire
Penny Hardaway
because you saw him in uniform for that
team you cheer for him you understand
he's gonna have a level of commitment
and that's the commitment that we now
have because we now feel that the
Hatchin
very when they hired our brother JaJuan
and it's not just a fat file
you know this rich either lies twin
right Louie bought Terry Mills from
Romeo Robinson Shawn Higgins Antoine
Joubert went to my high school Lesley
rocket more before me the general Gary
grant boy Tarpley is from Detroit
my high school coach Perry Watson
coached at Michigan while I was there
and coach Juwan and so there are so many
tentacles that were splintered at the
University of Michigan as it related to
our relationship with them but again
when Juwan Howard gets higher all of
that gets buried now we're all for one
one for all in supporting the program
and trying to continue to elevate with
John Beilein establishing and and you
and see Weber do you guys need a hatch
anything out yourselves Jalen of course
of course there's something that we're
gonna hash out as brothers as men that
will do off wax I'm pretty sure at some
time between now and the Union that
you're talking about but for those that
don't know we go back before Michigan
like we play on the Superfriends with
Curtis Hervey when we were 13 years old
going to st. Lula's going to Washington
DC we decided that we were going to go
to Michigan together he didn't wear
number 4 in high school I didn't wear
number 5 in high school we chose those
numbers because we were the last two to
sign a letter of intent so our
relationship go way deeper than Ann
Arbor
it starts in Detroit and not it we're
responsible adults it's up for us to be
leaders and men to show people that we
can have conflict resolution without
drama or without any disrespect and I
think the hiring of Juwan now also gives
us a baton to now give us a sense of
urgency to make it happen and I believe
and I'm sure that it will take place
yeah I got you on coming up in the next
hour and I'm genuinely excited about all
this Jalen and just to bring this all
full circle and input
button on it you know you will you
pointed out about how going from college
as a you know a teenager in your 20s and
then becoming a 40 year old and your
professional and then you were you know
your father or a mother or whatever as
you go throughout your life
what the Fab Five is done I mean I just
mentioned everything that you've done
get you've become at ESPN see web doing
what he's doing on Turner JaJuan is now
the head coach of Michigan basketball
I'm not completely familiar with what
Jimmy King and Ray Jackson are up to we
see palinka interestingly enough and it
was here in Los Angeles at the GM it is
amazing what has happened with that team
here now in 2019 Jalen our fingerprints
are everywhere and I literally in
Toronto just got finish doing a hit with
first take walk right out of the
building it was four people standing in
front of me one had a son named Jalen
one had a daughter named Jalen one of
them was named James I was taking
pictures with the signed autographs with
so it's bigger than just basketball and
not we've gotten a chance to graduate in
life it's a score to gain and it's the
game of life and your naysayers are
going to always judge you by your worst
moments or always going to throw in your
face what you can't do it what you
didn't accomplish so I want our story to
be one of maturity because what people
saw from us at collegiate students and
now hopefully what they're seeing from
us as taxpaying citizens and people that
are giving back to our community and
trying to have a positive influence and
successful individuals that they now can
trust strength and understand that they
can grow and be better as they continue
to get older and mature Jalen you the
man our best to everybody best to Molly
best to everybody okay and we'll chat
soon
that's mutual appreciation love don't
hesitate to reach out more call away
right back at you that's Jalen Rose at
Jalen Rose on Twitter at Jalen versus
everybody on Instagram right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the rich
and show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app